hello my name is shadi Ashton I and I'm
going to talk about computational audio
new in version 11 of the Wolfram
language the Wolfram language allows for
immediate representation of an audio
object all your objects can be in memory
and we're referencing a local or remote
file in memory audio objects like this
one store all of the data in the object
and this is good for efficient
representation and fast processing
however ability to link to local files
or remote files are also available in
the Wolfram language and as far as
processing representation and analysis
of audio objects all of them are treated
exactly the same and all functions
support all types of audio objects to
quickly compare the different modalities
of audio objects I'm reporting a few
properties of these three audio objects
that were imported into Mathematica and
then we can see that both count of an
in-memory audio object is significantly
larger
although the duration of it for instance
is smaller than the one that was sitting
on a on a server in the case of local
files and remote files we're just
linking to the file and the data is
streamed from the file into the Wolfram
language rather than being all imported
into the memory there are also options
available to the audio object for
instance the appearance is something
that specifies how the user interface of
an audio object should be displayed the
default is a basic user interface at
basic appearance that gives us a play
button and slider to show where the
position is and an ability to move this
slider to move the position a reset
button and icon that specifies whether
the object is in memory or referencing a
file or a local or a remote file
tooltips and expanders two other types
of European TSA's the minimal appearance
is simply just a play button and an
expander and we have also the detailed
appearance which in addition to
everything that were was available in
the basic appearance gives us the
looping ability to choose device and
change the volume as well as
ability to show the waveform or the
spectrogram of the audio object all your
objects in the Wolfram language may have
different number of channels we support
one for Mona two for stereo an arbitrary
number of channels data types range from
8-bit signed integers for compactness to
64-bit reals for precision and then
arbitrary sample rates are available
there are more options available in the
audio object to specify meta information
sample rates sound volume and so forth
so many of the functions that were
existing in Mathematica before the
introduction of the audio got updated to
work with the audio object and there
were so many other functions introduced
along with the audio object in order to
analyze visualize and process all the
objects in the domain of visualization
here I have two audio samples all your
plot is a new function that basically
shows a waveform plot of an audio signal
there are also various options available
to change the appearance and the theme
of the plot that is displayed here I
have only a single audio object this is
a two channel audio object but also
audio plot can be used to show multiple
signals at once periodogram and
spectrogram were available before in
Mathematica and now we are basically
upgrading we have upgraded them to work
with other objects as well all your
objects are very well integrated into
the rest of the Wolfram language
arithmetics like x and plus are
supported with all your objects and the
composition return is another audio
object which combines the two audio
signals in this case operations like
mean can be applied and apps can be
applied than anything else
basically to manipulate all your objects
are available statistical operations
such as Max and mean and so forth on a
single audio objects are also available
Wolfram language used to have various
number of filters in this case I'm
showing low pass filter and bener filter
on an audio signal all of those were
upgrade
to also work seamlessly with the
introduction of the audio object audio
generator is another function that got
introduced in this release we have
various models for oscillators and noise
in this case I am creating a sine signal
with a specific frequency 500 Hertz in
this case the given frequency can be
varying in time so here I specify a
function of frequency over time various
noise models available range from two
other color noise like things and then
custom generators can be created a
custom audio objects audio signals can
be created using functions and put and
processes for instance here I have
another sine tone or a signal generated
from the process basic everything
capabilities got added to mathematical
version 11 as well here we have a signal
of a female voice saying the word hello
three times hello hello hello adjusting
Athlete ood of the values basically
amplifying or attenuating is implemented
in a function called audio amplify hello
hello hello the sample rate of a signal
can be changed to something like for the
8k for DVD quality and that if I play it
it's going to sound the same trimming
and padding are also available so I can
take the first second of the audio
signal below or pad it by one second at
the beginning and the end hello hello
hello partitioning and splitting were
also introduced so in this case I'm
partitioning two chunks of one second or
I can give some various times and split
the audio at those time so in case one I
get signals of all same durations that
in case do I get signals of different
durations conform audio is another
utility function that takes a list of
audio objects in and conforms the
properties of those audio signals for
instance the set of ten audio signals
that I've extracted from example data
contain audio signals of different
number of channels different durations
types and sample rates and once pass
through conformed audio all of them have
the same properties and this is very
useful when we want to do batch
processing of a list of audio signals or
do some classification and so forth
audio composition is also available and
not only through the arithmetics and
prescience that i showed but also
through some new kit new functions and
capabilities that were added in version
11 so for instance here I'm creating two
signals one is a white noise and the
other one is a table of three three
notes converted to an audio I can join
them so I get noise notes noise
and if I plot them this will resemble
what was created in the previous cell or
we can overlay them so that they are
played at the same time on top of each
other
so I had only one second of noise and
three seconds of notes being played an
arbitrary compositions can be applied
using any other combination of
arithmetic s--
audio effects are another big topic in
the field of audio processing here we
get the same signal of the female voice
and I am applying a function called
audio delay to add a delayed signal to
itself one can also add reverberation to
simulate an environment like a church or
an or a stadium or a specific room
time stretching and pitch shifting or
another very commonly used effects time
stretching with an with a factor greater
than one makes the audio play slower
hello hello and using a factor smaller
than one makes it play faster pitch
shifting simply changes the pitch of an
audio signal without changing the
duration and this moves the pitch down
another set of functionality that got
added to version 11 or audio analysis
global measurements such as some
property extractions as well as global
measurements of histogram properties or
other properties are available through a
function called all your measurements
here we are computing a list of
properties for 10 audio signals again
taken from example data a number of
channels duration mean value max value
max app's value loudness and zero
crossing rate these are all important to
identify audio signals however more
typically local measurements are
interesting for comparison and analysis
of audio signals in this particular case
I'm computing the loudness as a time
series and this is the plot that says
that that shows the loudness of the
signal over time and for instance these
local computations can be used for
finding transients for finding peaks of
the loudness and this is just a plot
that shows the peaks on top of the
computed time series interval detection
can happen using all your local
measurements but also we have a function
called all your intervals here we have
yet another signal and we ask for
intervals where RMS amplitude is smaller
than a certain threshold given and
plotting those intervals on the waveform
plot the same scheme can happen for
other measurements such as fundamental
frequency and if we compute fundamental
frequency and plodded we see that we
have
different frequencies in sequence and we
can even run some function like find
clusters to find clusters of detected
fundamental frequencies to detect what
are the sequences of notes that were
played more convolved computation can
basically lead to higher level analysis
for instance here we are compiling
combining RMS amplitude and spectral
flatness to detect nine non voiced
regions of an audio signal the
requirement is for the RMS amplitude to
be small but for the spectral flatness
to not not to be so small and if I plot
their regions that detected intervals on
top of the waveform these are the
regions that are identified as non
voiced and we can remove those from an
audio signal so that I'm so I play that
before and after further analysis of
audio objects can allow for things like
computing a signature of an audio signal
here we are going with M FCC features of
an audio signal and a simple matrix plot
of the M FCC features which is 12
coefficients per chunk of data that is
compute that looks like that and we are
taking that and compute a distance
matrix for every column of that for
every column to every other column so
this is the signal on both sides of the
matrix and often people use these to
identify audio signals from each other
and similar features and can be used to
compare two different signals with each
other here for instance we have two
recordings of Alice in Wonderland
and by two different people and what
we're doing is that we are computing LPC
coefficients for both signals and these
are basically plots of LPC for the two
recordings and again computing the
distance matrix for one feature to
another which gives us sort of a
comparison between the two signals in
order to see the full list of
capabilities that are added we have
put all of the Lessing's of functions
and in the guide page for audio
processing and all the filters and
processing functions in signal
processing there are three tutorials
available for basics of an audio object
processing and synthesis of all the
objects and a lot of complete examples
on our marketing page thank you